chẳng có sự chia Tay nào ở đây cả
netizen
quay xe khi phát hiện loạt tương tác đầy ẩn ý giữa Shin
và ogenus ngông phủ nhận tin đồn đường AI nấy đi
nhà gái bắt trend
ủng hộ nhà trai đang lại như một cách đánh dấu chủ quyền
trước đó việc cả 2 unfollow nhau trên nhiều nền tảng
từng khiến khán giả tin rằng chuyện tình đã kết thúc
nhưng diễn biến mới lại khiến mọi suy đoán đảo chiều
Xin cùng hội bạn bất ngờ đu trend
Theo CA khúc mới của ojinus
từ bối cảnh đến nhân vật đều trùng khớp
khiến dân tình nghi ngờ cả 2 thực chất quay Chung một nơi
cùng thời điểm
chưa dừng lại ở đó
phía ojinus cũng có động thái rõ ràng khi đăng lại
toàn bộ video của Shin
như một cách âm thầm phản hồi
những tương tác này
đủ để netizen
hiểu rằng mối quan hệ giữa 2 người vẫn chưa hề nguội
đáng chú ý nhất là khoảnh khắc cuối clip
khi ojinus xuất hiện
bất ngờ có một bàn Tay kéo anh Ra khỏi khung hình
không cần nói cũng biết là của AI
và chính Chi tiết nhỏ đó lại khiến cộng đồng mạng
tan chảy vì quá đáng yêu
có vẻ như thay vì lời xác nhận chính thức
Shin và ojinus
đang chọn cách kể câu chuyện của mình bằng những
tín hiệu rất riêng
nhẹ nhàng nhưng đủ để AI cũng hiểu